hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to we've
seen some really weird team ups on this
show happening we see Michael Jordan
team up with Bugs Bunny Columbus teamed
up with a wood worm a dog teamed up with
a dolphin Whoopi Goldberg teamed up with
a dinosaur but by far the absolute worst
team-up ever is Whoopi Goldberg in the
dinosaur but jean-claude van damme and
Dennis Rodman come in a close second
this is TT I mean talk about a bizarre
combo was there really a group of people
out there who wanted to see these two
together who would sitting around in
their living room saying gosh you know
what be great
world peace no pollution and that
skittle headed basketball player teamed
up with the muscles from Brussels who
the hell shows that yellow line is Tommy
Boy I think you dating well whoever
chose it we got it so let's take a look
at the team-up that nobody demanded this
is double team so we start off with a
quiet opening for a monster truck rally
we see van Damme playing a secret agent
driving a truck full of plutonium out of
the hands of the Iraqi terrorists so
that's where the weapons of mass
destruction were they so 2003 well we
got explosions gunfire things getting
crushed
I had to weigh it's actually a pretty
good action see the only thing missing
is well giving a ground bend damn hasn't
said a line yet so I don't really think
there's any reason to care about what's
he does they align then I'll know
there's no reason to care about
so I can't wait to see what significance
this has on the plat was 100% pointless
three years later that scene never gets
mentioned again so as usual we're not
supposed to give a bad damn about it
oh my buddy give me a with a call so
turns out van Damme got married after
that mission is living happily with his
pregnant wife but then an old agent
friend comes by and makes him an offer
Stavros is back and we want it alive and
yes this scene has been done so many
times in other action movies you can
practically recite it word for word
so you know I'm retired come on you're a
jacket
you pay for material you're like
emilie's work
this is your last shot you know I could
forgive this movie if it came out in the
80s when everybody was doing this cliche
this is 1997 even Arnold was like dude
that shit is odd in fact it's so tired
we don't get a scene where he thinks it
over or talks to his wife the next cut
is literally him just on the mission I
mean I guess really do you need to see
where he talks it over you know he's
just gonna say yes it's like asking a
comedian if you can do a Charlie Sheen
Joe you had me at hello Sita it's a
little tight in the rear but it turns
out our bad guy played by Mickey Rourke
after nine and a half weeks but before
Sin City so tough times he's holding a
gun to the agent friend after he got Van
Damme on the assignment and by the way I
left you a present oh did he just lock
himself inside the car
dumbass agent is this
oh yeah he's not looking back at the
explosion because he just assumes the
guy got out of the car
what's to look back at it's not like
he'd be stupid enough to not know how to
open a door
no wonder the NIMH and amp bag heavies
agents can't even get past childproof
safety devices Kutta Antwerp or Van
Damme enters into a cross-dressing bar
well I think I get the feeling this is
where we're gonna see Rob wah
what does your hair stick for the ROI
what is been fun it turns out Robin is
the weapons man that Van Damme is
supposed to meet up with well Lisi
doesn't dress egg look or hangout in any
plate that would be the least bit
suspicious who's that Rudo I may not
have reindeer I do have the best house
in the business you know I have to admit
this is weird even by Rodman standards I
mean this is the first movie he's ever
done did he really just look at this
script and say ball gags on the wall
scuba diving in leather jean-claude van
damme I feel this offense gets the glory
but defense wins the game what a
terrible basketball pun but don't worry
folks there's a lot more where I came
from gentlemen this is Delta one forget
you've ever seen him well it is
jean-claude Van Damme forgetting it is
pretty easy he has information that's
table rows will be servicing tomorrow
afternoon somewhere around here so they
look at their board game to figure out
how to take out wark and they get ready
to make the hit but Van Damme sees work
with his son and finds that he just
can't pull the trigger with him watching
which gives war plenty of time to fire
back
simple Van Dam's men and horsemen start
firing any and no your computer is not
having trouble loading that's actually
how they shot I guess the dirty DVD
style of editing was very popular back
then so turns out Rourke's kid gets shot
and naturally this really pisses him off
really he's firing while on one of the
rides you son of a
you shot myself I will have my revenge
he goes inside a hospital and shoots all
the staff so he can properly monologue
in peace this favorite thing in the
world used to be let me go riding this
little pony in weakens little Posca can
you speak a little louder I can't hear
your pretentiousness when you whisper
well it was six years old
but work puts a grenade in the baby's
bed giving new meaning to the term baby
all gee I'm sorry if you weren't dead
poor baby it's gonna go through his
entire life with an incredible fear of
fire and Belgians so fainting wakes up
on an island of all places where a voice
tells him what's going on Quinn Jack
Paul or 1959 agent Quinn achieved clean
opportunity to acquire alpha but target
alpha escaped you went soft soft agents
reliability but because of your skills
you've been assigned to the colony ah
did I forget to mention you a horrible
actor you're dead already
at least that's what your wife and the
rest of the world have been told Wow
he dug from himself throwing a TV away
from himself
no wonder he's a liability Alex go
Smythe the tax man you were killed six
years ago got spin six years already so
this is goldsmith played by Peter
Freedman gotta lock it turns out this is
a secret place where both agents and
terrorists work together to solve global
problems and everyone in the world
thinks they're dead
we're too valuable to kill and too
dangerous to set free
welcome to the collar
okay where do I begin to talk about this
mountain of not making sense first of
all why are agents and terrorists
working together did they just totally
forget about the fact that they have
different goals second most of these
people were out of control killers
Vanden didn't shoot a guy the exact
opposite of why everyone else is there
and wasn't he retired anyway so how does
that make him a danger third they keep
them doing the jobs that they were
already doing before so why don't they
just keep them doing the jobs they're
already doing before the only difference
is now they're doing their spy work
inside well why didn't you just down
raid them to begin with
just give them a desk job that's easy
enough why do you have to create an
island with lasers in the water
why do you have to tell everybody
they're dead why the hell would anybody
follow this crazy plan is this guy just
really good at convincing people too bad
the hovitos don't know either way i do
belloq indeed indiana indeed
so they damn just sort of goes along
with it never saying you bastards can be
back my wife or anything he just sort of
goes with the flow along with all the
terrorists to dying for your god fuck
that shit they got a pool but suddenly
Van Damme sees a marking that indicates
that his wife may be in danger of course
he can let this incredible unstoppable
team of power take care of the situation
but nope he decides not to tell anyone
at all and spends most of his time
planning his escape rescuing her for
himself which of course would take days
and days to set into motion but hey at
least he's not letting the other guys
get it done faster we of course get
those scenes that we get in every Van
Damme movie where he starts bending like
Stretch Armstrong and of course he plans
his way out by the way have you noticed
something missing from this movie that
is freaking Rodman even the poster shows
up in the foreground like he's the main
star and yet we're 43 minutes in
then maybe five of those minutes have
Rob in it what did he have a game to
play
maybe he got drunk again at Celebrity
Apprentice I don't know but it turns out
those lasers in the water do go off at
one point and that's when the plane
flies by to drop off supplies which
makes you wonder why they didn't just
land and physically hand them the
supplies to begin with but who am I to
say how to run a crazy island I guess
someone happened to be scuba diving at
the same time and he tries to stop it
newsflash Tim with a plastic bag isn't
gonna do much underwater he already
can't brave Van Damme escapes and
catches a ride on the plane that takes
back the other car he kiss their asses
and gives them to fly him back to Edward
where finally we get to see slushy head
again just a mere forty seven minutes in
yeah I liked being left with the Belgian
waffle house never understanding what
the heli says you bring cash I'll pay
you later Bruce I just declared a 7-day
cool off damn man don't get mad
I'll give you three CIA bank account
numbers well that's nice but we don't
have much use for a bank I got number I
look at you I see nothing but trouble I
kind of like trouble don't they jump out
of a plane and get ready to land where
are their parachutes you're wondering oh
they have something even better than
that they land in a giant basket fall I
am dead serious
a giant basketball now that's what I
call Hank hat and not only that it
doesn't bounce and it seems incredibly
easy to break apart so yeah third bones
would pretty much be liquid jello by
this point but in the movie world it's a
delightful little send up
two-pointer he goes to his house where
he thinks his newborn child is but it
turns out the bad guys have replaced the
baby with a bomb a bomb B yeah I look on
the flame totally engulfs him several
feet away from the window and yet
somehow he jumps out untouched he must
have bought a little sunscreen with the
massive amount of money he has in his
bank account so he fights off the bad
guys and makes it to a safe place with
rod who finds a letter and steals it
away from Van Damme well it's not a bomb
everything access closed I would love to
get paid those mega cons are from Moses
its bank account pronounced euros well
is this a sonogram of my son we find
that work be friends van Dan's wife
without anybody recognizing who he is
and he helps take care of her during her
pregnancy Stavros has my boy you go back
to Antwerp
I'll get your money I pin my debts you
pay your tits I pin my this next should
be telling me I am the love ah why are
you telling this before
what do you care you always play defense
right time to get out the bench the best
defense is a strong offense well he has
been out of this movie for a bit I guess
he had to make up for it with three
basketball puns in a row taking you to
the hospital you'll be safer there
so Van Damme dresses up like a John
Lennon Pauly Shore pancake and tries to
sneak up on Bork
Quinn notice what if watch
I'm bigger than Jesus before cast back
up and they had themselves another
little shooter I'll have to call it a
five-point yes you played basketball
please shut up work escapes and makes
his way to the pregnant wife while she's
giving birth to her son Robin he'll
spend and find her through get this
cyber marks no I'm serious that's what
they called it these monks have been
collecting information on Rome for 500
years
cyber - holy shit why couldn't we be
about these guys just their 2-minute
cameo is a million times better than
anything else we've seen come if you're
not gonna do it somebody else has to we
need to see cyber locks your move creep
so they find out where the wife is but
it turns out she already gave birth and
Rourke has stolen the baby you go get
your boy
I'll take your
the old me so Van Damme goes to a
Coliseum where work has really gone
aloud and preparing a climax but mine's
in the ground decorate them with crosses
the babies in the middle took his shirt
off even throwing a fucking tiger for
all this it's like gladiator meets Grand
Theft Auto you gotta give him an A for
creativity yeah way to look after my
wife wire so Roman gets the baby out who
surprisingly doesn't cry despite the
fact he's on a motorcycle I'm right next
to a tiger but of course Van Damme can't
leave the score I'm finish let's just
get the hell out of this place gonna bro
you're taking my son out to go Stavros
uh wouldn't it make more sense if Rodman
took care of the bad guy and you lived
happily ever after with your loving
family trust me your ego is big enough
to survive if you don't throw the
finishing punch so Van Damme and work
have a martial arts fight stepping
carefully not to hit any of the minds
but again Rodman doesn't do what he said
he would do he comes back to help Van
Damme just leaving the baby on the
fucking ground it's just a tiger
infested heavily explosive Coliseum of
death it's just like a Chucky Cheese
thankfully Bala comes to save the baby
and we see work has messed up and
stepped on one of the minds once he
takes his foot off he goes up in smoke
Oh
oh my god we have Mickey work on a mine
in the middle of the minefield with a
ferocious tiger in a Coliseum with
jean-claude Van Damme Dennis Rodman
Ballack and a baby in a basket if this
does not deliver the most fucking epic
imagery I have ever seen in my entire
life I have lost all hope in mankind
oh let's see what happens
Wow okay all right I'll go back and talk
about the entire scene butter oh my
fucking god first of all look at Mickey
Rourke's face he just knows that if he's
gonna go out he has to go out with a
fucking tire eating him while he's being
blown up alive clearly there's no other
option well I may as well give them what
they want
second we have a whole Colosseum going
up in flames and yet they still manage
to get their product placements in there
hell they're literally throwing the mass
third with all these explosions and all
this fire it's hiding behind a Coke
machine that saves the day that's a new
one that's an you know okay I'm not
usually aware when I'm starting an
internet meme but my god this has to be
the internet meet it is far too good
okay there is jumping the shark nuking
the fridge
ladies and gentlemen this is frying the
cock this is the ultimate in awesomely
and laughably implausible oh we might as
well just ended here folks I'm not gonna
top that I mean the movie pretty much
does anyway bellick says they're cool
and they just go off their separate wait
he doesn't meet up with his wife or
anything but honestly who wants to see
that after this scene I mean just go out
on that high note so yeah the rest of
the movie is dumb and laughably silly
but it was totally worth it just for
that moment I want that image framed and
put on my wall it's that awesome we mere
mortals wish we could go out in such a
cool way so if you want a stupid movie
but with the mother of all endings chick
this flick out it's totally worth it
just for that one minute
of ecstasy I'm Anastasia Craig I
remember I'm sure as hell not gonna
fucking forget she's the head of state
patrol between our lives on the family
jewels bank account numbers